with the advancement of technology in
2077 we're able to do things we
otherwise couldn't do
like sending data or sending money to
each other by touching personal links or
the ability to scan the environment
through our eyes
these are just some of the many things
people in 2077 can do thanks to
advancements in other fields of research
we can also cure illnesses and diseases
that wasn't possible before but because
of this rises new illnesses and old
illnesses with different methods of its
sprouting for example poor nutrition and
mental isolation can be caused by
overuse of brain dance those previously
mentioned effects aren't new illnesses
but the method by which you acquire them
being brain dance is
but there is a completely new illness
that is specific to cyberpunk and the
topic of today's video
cyberpsychosis we hear about
cyberpsychosis from regina after
visiting victor at his ripperdoc clinic
regina who is a fixer in watson tells us
that a few people believe that cyber
psychosis can be treated it sounds
bizarre as it's something no one really
thought could happen as no one has made
any significant breakthroughs yet regina
says she'll call you if any other cyber
psychos pop up and recommends that you
knock them out and not kill them
there are 17 specific missions of
cyberpsychos in cyberpunk that we can do
but you can find some in smaller things
like gigs and side jobs every now and
then cyberpsychosis is defined as a
mental illness specifically a
dissociative disorder caused by an
overload of cybernetic augmentations to
the body
those affected by cyber psychosis are
called cyber psychos which are those who
have psychotic tendencies that are
enhanced by their cybernetics that
doesn't mean only psycho people can
experience this as cyberpsychosis can
affect anyone with cybernetic
modifications but the less empathetic or
psychologically unstable a person is
beforehand the easier it is to develop
this illness
simple things like a metal hand may not
trigger it but if your whole body is
covered in
cybernetic implants then you're more
likely to for its symptoms it can range
anywhere from self-isolation of family
members and friends to full-on outbursts
and violent attacks
people affected by this tend to stop
feeling human and become more machine
they stop doing things they enjoy
whether that's hobbies recreational
activities or simply eating and sleeping
as well as finding human interaction
very irritating
while the most common of cyber psychos
are aggressive towards people some
aren't they could be compulsive liars or
have fragmented personalities we can see
quite a few people in game across a
bunch of side missions that showcase
these from gangs to symbol residents
characters not related to cyber psycho
side quests would be lizzy wizzy and
adam
smasher lizzy isn't attacking us as
there's no violent outbreaks but is
obsessed with how her body operates now
and killed her lover after the first
sidequest we did with her and with adam
he does have a tendency to kill people
and has a hatred for everyone in arasaka
the company he works for the only reason
he works for them though is because they
saved his life ages ago these two don't
show the typical signs of cyber
psychosis but they seem to have the more
lesser known symptoms at least i believe
so lizzy is becoming more and more
obsessed with her metallic body that's
the part feeling more
machine than human and she also killed
her ex-lover lizzy's case is more of a
gray area considering the fact that her
ex-lover did go behind her back to try
to put her in that secure soul program
that johnny was in which is [ __ ] up
but regardless he was afraid of her
after her transformation and she ended
up losing control trying to push him and
ended up crushing his spine killing him
which we see in the second side quest
adam while a killer he's a trained and
professional one he just has a complete
hatred for people which is that
irritation of human interaction part of
the symptoms there are no in-game texts
or articles that prove they have cyber
psychosis but they do have similar
symptoms so it's something interesting
to think about in terms of in-game
missions we see a person from the
badlands who has his house completely
full of automated defenses
this resident has had a troubled past
and some mad paranoia he ordered tons of
technology from all the defense systems
we see at his house to a whole on
netrunner chair this caused a power
outage and when the family came by to
check to see what was wrong
the defense systems turned on and killed
them which made him lose it even more
another one of these cyber psycho
incidents is near a pier when we arrive
at the crime scene we see a psychotic
woman there we then subdue her and then
learn the harsh reality the cyber
psycho's name is dao and on her body is
a shard
years ago she did a prank on her sister
and ruined her wedding making her a
laughing stock as revenge her sister had
dao implanted with the worst
implants on jig jig street in an attempt
to as she says ruin her beautiful body
what's even worse is that her sister is
getting married to dao's current fiance
it seems she also modified herself so
her fiance kenny wouldn't know the
difference they were then going to get
married take photos in front of her
favorite restaurant just to torment her
this is already one of the worst stories
we've talked about but if you look
further there are even more clues that
make it worse
around the area is cameras yes
photographers aren't uncommon at
weddings but this looks more like a film
crew not one photographer near the crime
scene is two shards
one about dao's sister lin who got a
message from a woman named celine and
the other being about celine's notes
some of the lines say quote i've heard
you've been worried about security at
the wedding we'll put it out of your
mind as one of our biggest stars you
know that comfort and peace of mind is
our top priority i would not let your
sister ruin your perfect day further
ahead it says dow's in a coma and will
wake up once you and kenny are sipping
watermelo mojitos on the beach
the notes are titled saigon sisters
treatments some of the more notable
lines are the scene opens up with a
close-up of kenny and lin
posing for wedding pictures camera colon
panning on the figure of the motorboat
is a terrifying double of lin
borged out with a face contorted in pain
and rage it's lynn's sister dao
dow angrily confronts her sister
accusing her of putting her in a coma by
spiking her wine
dow hurls herself at her sister but
security steps in at the last moment and
they all tumble into the waves
the final scene of the season comes to
an end with a loud splash and
scene it's a [ __ ] reality tv show
it's unclear if the original shard we
read from lin tadao was real or just
used by the tv crew to make dao angrier
and make her come to the wedding but
this whole situation is now more
infuriating than sad
a tv crew looking for the perfect ending
to their reality tv show said this fake
scenario by lying to lynn that dao was
in a coma when she in fact wasn't and
the possibility of faking the original
message that was sent to dial by her
sister lin to entice her also they can
get some sweet footages traumatic and
honestly [ __ ] disgusting
the last one is called smoke on the
water we see another pier with tons of
dead bodies an archived conversation
from two people hideyoshi and ken
talk about a killer who's hunting them
claiming he killed 20 of them already
and tons of their businesses have been
shut down it seems like they captured
the killer's daughter and he wants her
back because of his destruction they
plan to give him his daughter back but
ambush him when he's going to retrieve
her as we could tell the plan didn't
work out as not only is the killer still
alive but the ambush clearly failed
under the pier is a van and inside is
sophia ramirez safe to assume the
daughter of our killer diego ramirez
they never had plans of giving her back
in the first place
according to the scan she seemed to be a
sex worker so it's possible this is how
they caught her it seemed like they were
going to maybe sell her to the highest
bidder but diego was hot on their tail
and they needed to kill her and get rid
of the evidence they then called diego
to meet up for a trade of his daughter
but they ambushed him instead and diego
killed them
all three of these incidents and the
others we're going to look at are tragic
stories of people either with just bad
luck or rooted with some deeper mental
issues that unfortunately weren't looked
at by professionals
besides typical people we also have to
think about the gangs as well
booster gangs are the most common of
gangs that have cyber psychos within
them booster gangs as a name may not
sound familiar but their gangs enhanced
with cybernetic technology and while
most gangs in cyberlink have cybernetics
the most notable game that goes above
and beyond is maelstrom this gang is
considered a booster gang as it's
obviously go very deep with their
cybernetics like royce where half his
face is off just to fit the implant
we see a couple people a part of
maelstrom who have had cyberpsychosis in
the game the one wall not a part of
maelstrom the gang is involved in some
way it seemed maelstrom was looking for
volunteers to test some new cyberware
but because no one showed up they just
started kidnapping random people and
they found some random valentino member
they kidnapped him and stuffed him with
implants and because he was implanted
with so many of them in a small amount
of time his body didn't adjust to it all
causing him to go psycho
we see his last words in a farewell note
talking to a woman named tamara about
killing himself as he's slowly turning
crazier and crazier by the hour since he
looks like a maelstrom member the
valentinos wouldn't take him back so no
matter what he does he's basically [ __ ]
at least he got the chance to get some
revenge and kill them when he went
psycho but it's still sad to hear what
happened to him that's why it's always
nice to knock them out and not kill them
in these missions as you're no better
than the max tech guards as we'll get
too soon the kid from this game just had
loads of bad luck and even though we
don't get to physically see what happens
to him it's nice to know that he and
others like him would go to therapy and
hopefully recover as it's better to go
to therapy and not recover then
just not go at all at least you're
giving yourself a chance to in one area
off the usual beaten path at a dead end
we see a ritual scene with tons of dead
maelstrom members as we investigate we
gain more context on the story
even get spooked by an apparition of the
person who was quote unquote sacrificed
the tub in the middle is covered in
blood and guts and after some time the
person emerges from the tub and attacks
us on site
it seems like in some ways she was
willingly a part of the ritual but
because of all the cybernetics and just
like our previous guy she went berserk
and killed her friends the side mission
does provide some cool insight as it
seems that women are more resistant to
cyber psychosis there's no explanation
why but it's just some interesting food
for thought
our last maelstrom gang-related psycho
is actually within the gang itself
during the first setup mission we go to
all foods and we hear about brick the
previous leader being dethroned by royce
while in one area we find a shard that's
a conversation between brick and another
member who talks about royce taking over
and not wanting that to happen
rick is content with the decision and
won't stop royce but this other man
ellis is not having it he seems like
brick's last loyal member as most went
to royce immediately when he rose to
power
because he liked brick so much he was
mad at the others for joining royce's
side
other members like hoof and sanders were
sent to take care of him but ellis went
crazy and attacked all of them
sadly the only effective and simple
treatment at the moment for these people
is death and
max tech has a special task force for
cyber psychos the group is called
psychosquad with the whole intention of
subduing and killing cyber psychos but
they usually kill them as it's just much
easier than capturing them one instance
was a guy up on a bridge
he was then attacked by cops in which he
killed all of them thankfully we got to
him in time before maxtec showed up as
they would have easily slaughtered him
we discovered from him that he was a
combat veteran obviously shown from all
the fourth corporate war shards in the
area
he was a part of a ptsd shield policy to
combat the trauma he got as a benefit
from his work
since he was fired from the company they
then terminated his enrollment in the
program which caused him to lose money
thanks to no job then this spiraled out
of control causing him to have to
foreclose his home and become homeless
with the only method of combating ptsd
with street drugs the state he was in
after all of this went down
is what we see when we find him on a
bridge a deranged man attacking anyone
nearby
one thing regina mentions though is that
some of these missions may have cyber
psychos like the environment they're in
their mental state etc all points to
cyberpsychosis but it's not exactly
confirmed i'm not sure if the condition
we find this man in is the work of
cyberpsychosis but it's definitely a
good highlight for how terrible the
government is regardless
the government has the ability to track
people down who buy loads of cyberware
and keep a close eye on them due to the
rise
of cyber psychosis but for some people
for obvious reasons they don't like the
government peeking at them constantly so
which is why they visit river docks as
we know some of their services are legal
but some conduct illegal deals like
installing military-grade cybernetics
into people
assuming they are subdued and captured
they undergo intense therapy they're
strapped down and stripped of all
cybernetics then they jack into a custom
braindance where a cyberpsychologist
attempts to piece their personality back
together after weeks and months the
cyber psycho slowly regains their
humanity and may even have a chance of
getting implants again but the mental
damage has already taken a toll on them
and will mostly stay with them for the
rest of their lives these were just a
taste of the 17 cyber psychos you can
encounter in game i highly recommend
doing these missions as not only do they
provide lots of xp and money but the
story stories a simple scene can provide
like with the sisters of the ritual make
it so much more enjoyable to uncover all
the secrets behind it and
arguably it's more entertaining than
some of the main story content like the
v if you do enjoyed let me know if
you've done some of these missions
yourself in the comments down below and
if you have let me know your favorite
one i got for more cyberpunk content and
just more lore related videos on other
games in the future thank you for the
support on the past two cyberpunk videos
you guys are fantastic but with that
take care everyone and goodbye
[Music]
hmm